alors les jeux j'en ai fait cinq depuis
81 1985 jusqu'en 2003 donc s'étaient
enchaînés quoi c'est sûr qu'il ya une
évolution les moyens de 1985 avec les
moyens de l'aider à nier que j'ai fait
c'était donc en 2003 à maurice
c'était pas du tout les mêmes le sportif
lui même aussi a changé la manière de
s'entraîner la manière s'alimenter tout
a changé finalement c'est sûr que pour
d'autres sportifs qui ont la chance de
pouvoir évoluer après aux championnats
d'europe ou du monde s'est subitement
les jeux peut-être ça c'est un niveau
peut-être en dessous mais moi pour moi
personnellement c'est vraiment le summum
conçu ni à fort beau les premiers les
premiers jus disent ils c'est tiago
savoir que la première sélection
premiers jeux des îles participation
assez évasive de mapa mois moyenne dans
l'ensemble très bon soonias et puis
quand on est très mauvais c'est à dire
l'ambiance générale qui avait deux c'est
juste 85 samassa ne s'était pas c'était
pas la grosse grosse entente entre les
délégations aux mauriciennes et et
réunionnais c'était très très chaud il
fallait absolument gagner à tout prix
presque par tous les moyens
moi je ressentais ça j'ai vécu comme ça
après peut-être que d'autres c'était pas
du tout sa peau mais pour moi c'était ce
à quoi on va aller le poids des ans on a
toujours quelques petits regrets
malheureusement et bakchich
j'ai refusé une sélection les des jeux
en 2007
en 2007 c'était madagascar souvenir de
madagascar de 80 ou 90 m'avait rattraper
un petit peu aussi c'étaient des
souvenirs mitigés avec le côté festif du
sport et puis le côté le côté d'une
population en souffrance malgache
ça ça m'avait marqué et 2007 quand j'ai
refusé des chiottes penser à cet état
d'esprit avait peu partagé entre la fête
et
la misère au final ça nous a permis non
en tant que homme en tant que athlètes
de de mieux de mieux comprendre les
autres délégations les d'apprendre à se
connaître aussi finalement quoi de la
misère tout les conflits tout ce qu'on
entend maintenant ces désagréments
perpétuellement agressé par passer
passer ces moments de vie on va dire et
le sport justement ça ne vous aide pas
comment à passer à passer au dessus de
tout ça